Gloria Steinem,
one of the leading lights
of modern feminism.
You will surely go down
in the annals of history
just as surely
as Lisa Lampanelli will go down
in the locker room
of the Houston Rockets.
(LAUGHTER)
Hey, BoJack,
are you a Zoe or a Zelda?
Don't know what that means.
-Well, I was talking to Wayne.
-Who's Wayne?
-I'm Wayne.
-Wayne's writing an article
about me for BuzzFeed .
Fun fact:
Wayne is also my ex-boyfriend.
Ha! You're funny.
MR. PEANUTBUTTER:
Pretty cool, eh, BoJack?
Diane's writing a book
about you,
Wayne's writing
an article about me.
We're the same!
How could you think that
that's the same?
My book will be in libraries
for hundreds of years.
Your BuzzFeed article
will be crammed
between an animated GIF of a cat
falling asleep
and a list of fun facts
about Legally Blonde.
-Ha! Classic Zoe.
-I still don't know
what that means.
Well, are you familiar
with Mr. Peanutbutter's House?
Do you mean his sitcom
that coincidentally
had the exact same premise
as my sitcom?
Not the exact same.
Mr. Peanutbutter's House
featured a pair of twins,
Zoe and Zelda.
Zelda was the sunny,
fun-loving extrovert.
Look at my pumpkin,
Mr. Peanutbutter.
-Pretty smile, Zelly-belly.
-AUDIENCE: Aww...
Whereas Zoe was the smart,
cynical introvert.
My pumpkin's throwing up
because Halloween encourages
excessive consumption
of refined sugar
at a time
when obesity rates are sky high.
Plus, Halloween costumes
are a gateway to casual racism.
Why don't I keep the knife,
Zo-bo?
-♪Who's that dog? ♪
-♪Mr. Peanutbutter ♪
♪Knick-knack, paddywhack
Give a dog a bone ♪
Now, was the show's acting
ham-fisted
and the writing moronic?
-No?
-Yes,
but the Zoe/Zelda paradigm
rang true.
I believe everyone's
either a Zoe or a Zelda.
For example, Nixon was a Zoe
and Kennedy, a Zelda.
It's R2-D2 and C-3PO,
Zooey and Emily Deschanel.
So Zooey's a Zoe?
No, Zooey's a Zelda.
Emily's the Zoe.
What a crazy world.
So which one are you, BoJack?
I think I'm... above this.
Said the Zoe.